llegamos aquí
buenas tardes con todos ustedes qué
grato poder estar aquí y qué grato
también poder compartir este tiempo con
personas tan interesantes y con speakers
pues también que nos han antecedido pues
bueno vamos a hablar de un tema muy
importante que lo pueden ustedes leer
ahí lo importante no es lo que te
llevarás sino lo que vas a dejar hay
cosas tan obvias tan obvias que
definitivamente pasan desapercibidas
para nosotros en las cuales no
reflexionamos y una de estas cosas tan
obvias es precisamente esta que en
nuestra vida tiene fecha
de expiración
nuestra vida tiene fecha de caducidad
nosotros vivimos sin pensar en eso pero
en realidad nos guste o no nos guste
tarde o temprano en algún momento
nuestra vida más tendrá un final y es en
ese momento donde nosotros tenemos que
preguntarnos
que nos vamos a llevar
que vamos a llevarnos de este mundo
y definitivamente la respuesta a esa
pregunta es absolutamente nada
una pregunta más importante debería ser
que vamos a
qué huella dejaremos en este mundo
pero lastimosamente no nos percatamos de
eso porque nos olvidamos precisamente de
entender esto que nuestra vida tiene
fecha de expiración
no sé si han escuchado ustedes hablar de
este término que dice no somos
arquitectos de nuestro perdón somos
arquitectos de nuestro destino pero en
realidad nosotros no somos arquitectos
de nuestro destino porque que es el
destino el destino está compuesto por
acontecimientos circunstanciales es
decir por aquellas cosas que nosotros no
los provocamos que siempre solamente
pasan son circunstancias que sucede el
conjunto de esos acontecimientos
circunstanciales definitivamente marcan
nuestro destino un ejemplo de esto
pensemos precisamente en la vida la vida
tiene un inicio y también tiene un final
uno no decide cuándo nacer dónde nacer o
cómo nacer así como tampoco uno no
decide cuándo morir dónde morir o cómo
morir pero qué es lo que sí podemos
decidir
como vivir es decir si nosotros hacemos
la relación de la vida como que fuese
una línea en el que tiene el inicio y
tiene el final lo decidimos sobre el
inicio no decidimos sobre el final pero
decidimos sobre el trayecto como
queremos vivir
el problema es que el mundo nos ha
impuesto a los otros parámetros
equivocados nos ha puesto a nosotros
parámetros que probablemente lo hemos
dado por sentado que son correctos y no
necesariamente son correctos por ejemplo
esta famosa imagen de la autoestima
se han visto ustedes verdad
en el que un gato se ve en el espejo y
se ve como un león y uno puede decir wow
entonces el secreto para tener una
autoestima es verme como un león cuando
soy un gato en realidad ese no es la
autoestima
lo real debería ser que el gato se mire
en el espejo y se vea como gato se
valore como gato y vea las
potencialidades que tiene como gato
dicho de otra manera lo realmente
importante es como te ves a ti
como te aprecia es a ti pero sobre todo
valorarte como realmente eres
no todos somos iguales hay unos que son
más altos otros más pequeños los más
solícitos otros más delgaditos no
importa lo importante es valorar que tal
como tú eres y no hacerte una figura
distorsionada de ti mismo sino aprender
a reconocer las potencialidades que tú
tienes así como también probablemente
también tus limitaciones y esforzarte
por tratar de superar esas limitaciones
precisamente aprovechando sus fortalezas
entonces este parámetro o esta figura
definitivamente no es la correcta la
idea es que te autosugestión es pensando
que eres otra persona o que te mires
como otra persona sino que te valores
tal y como tú eres
los parámetros que el mundo nos ha
puesto tienen que ver más con el bien
tener
con el bienestar pero no con el bien ser
el mundo nos impone parámetros como por
ejemplo el tipo de casa que debemos
tener el tipo de vehículo que debemos
tener o inclusive el tipo de celular que
debemos tener
y eso nos lleva solamente al bien tener
en algunos casos del bienestar
pero nos olvidamos de invertir tiempo en
el bien sea
cuanto tiempo realmente lo invertimos
para nosotros para ser mejores seres
humanos mejores personas entonces la
pregunta definitivamente es lo que nos
vamos a llevar
sino que vamos a dejar el mundo ha hecho
que invirtamos el orden de valores y ese
orden de valores así que nos afanemos
por muchas cosas
hace algún tiempo atrás tuve que acudir
a un velorio de una chica de 15 años
15 años con cáncer
y ahí estaba el féretro ahí estaba el
cadáver de la chica y me ponía a pensar
en ese momento
donde esté la fan
dónde está la preocupación dónde está
aquellas cosas por las cuales nos
hablamos los pelos y por las cuales
muchas veces nos afanamos tanto cuando
llegue ese momento definitivamente nada
de eso tendrá sentido
lo que sí tiene sentido es que legado
dejas que trascendencia dejas que huella
dejas
al final de la vida nada absolutamente
como les decía hace un momento nos vamos
a llevar todas las cosas que acumulas te
todo el dinero todas las propiedades que
probablemente acumulas te no te sirven
absolutamente de nada
por lo tanto la respuesta correcta es
que vamos
a dejar
qué huella dejaremos en aquellas
personas que amamos
en nuestros padres en nuestros hijos en
nuestra esposa o esposo que vaya vamos a
dejar en aquellas personas que comparten
tiempo con nosotros nuestros compañeros
de trabajo o inclusive nuestros amigos
la persona que probablemente saludamos
todo el día y todos los días a lo mejor
a la entrada el portero que ya dejamos
en las personas que nos conocen porque
nos van a recordar cuál va a ser la
trascendencia he aprendido algo en el
tiempo de vida que llegó que por cierto
ya es bastante antes solía decir en el
corto tiempo de vida que llegó pero ya
esa frase tuvo que cambiar con el tiempo
precisamente he aprendido algo al
respecto de esto que el éxito en la vida
no radica en lo que nos pasa
sino en la forma como reaccionamos ante
lo que nos pasa no son los
acontecimientos circunstanciales los que
van a marcar nuestro destino sino la
forma como nosotros reaccionamos ante
esos acontecimientos circunstanciales
que saben que la vida a veces nos pone
retos tan terribles y muchas veces nos
cuestiona a nuestros propios conceptos y
no se enfrenta a esos conceptos y eso es
algo que precisamente me pasó hace unos
un par de días
el sábado en la noche tipo 8 de la noche
estaba yo ya en mi casa dispuesto a
descansar
y de pronto mi esposa recibe una llamada
telefónica
una noticia terrible
acababan de atropellar a mi madre
si le ven atropellado a mi mal
una moto le había atropellado producto
de ese accidente mi madre tiene siete
costillas rotas
está realmente complicada su brazo su
pierna
y para nosotros fue un golpe super duro
toda la noche pasamos con ella en el
hospital decir un montón de radiografías
tomografías y un montón de cosas
los desocupados tipo 4 de la mañana en
la que hicieron referencia a otro
hospital nos fuimos a descansar y
teníamos que regresar al hospital y
cuando yo regresaba al hospital
manejando mi vehículo le hice un
comentario a mi esposa
le digo no tengo cabeza para nada
y atrás dije no tengo cabeza para nada
sabía que tenía que preparar aparte de
que sabía que tenía que hablar de estos
conceptos y yo le dije ese momento a mi
esposa no tengo cabeza para nada
y con la inteligencia y la sabiduría que
dios les da a las esposas mi esposa me
dijo
hoy en mauricio
tienes que aplicar lo que enseñas
tienes que aplicar los conceptos que tú
enseñas
y ante esa sabiduría no hice nada más
que guardar silencio y seguir manejando
no podía cuestionar lo que ella me decía
porque tenía razón es tan fácil hablar
es tan fácil decir pero qué difícil es
aplicarlo en la vida personal
y mientras yo iba meditando en el
volante yo decía que puedo sacar de aquí
si mi madre sufrió un accidente que
puedo sacar de aquí llegamos al hospital
tipo 11 de la mañana llaman por teléfono
a los familiares de maría isabel a rauch
que se llama mi mamá entonces yo acudo
y voy donde estaba mi madre
y nos habían llamado porque era la hora
de darles de comer y yo le veo a mi
madre allí con el brazo enyesado la
pierna enyesada con el otro brazo
conectado a unos tubos y algunas cosas y
le vi tan vulnerable a mi madre
y tuve una gran oportunidad la vida me
dio una gran oportunidad
en ese momento yo pude darle de comer a
mi madre en la boca
y es más para que no resulte tan difícil
para ella le hice a manera de avión para
que pueda seguir comiendo
y en ese momento yo reflexiones dijo
probablemente esa es la misma estrategia
que utilizó mi madre cuando yo era
pequeño
y en ese momento dije pude sacar algo
positivo de esta situación compartió un
tiempo hermoso con mi madre
y ahí todo tuvo sentido no es lo que nos
pasa sino la forma como nosotros
reaccionamos ante lo que nos pasa
tú no decidiste los padres que tener
tú no decidiste el hogar donde nacer
pronto si decides qué tipo de padre más
hacer qué tipo de padre van a tener tus
hijos en qué hogar van a nacer tus hijos
eso si decides no nos afanemos entonces
en aquellas cosas que no podemos influir
que no podemos cambiar invirtamos
nuestro tiempo en aquellas cosas que si
podemos influir en aquellas cosas que si
podemos cambiar yo creo que tenemos
nosotros una misión existencial
y dejar un legado dejar huella dejar
trascendencia la vida es demasiado corta
como para afanarse la vida es demasiado
corta como para no perdonar como para
guardar rencor guardar resentimiento la
vida no es más que un paréntesis de
miedo de la eternidad es tan fugaz y es
tan frágil que cuando yo le veía a mi
madre ahí me di cuenta que tan frágil es
la vida
y a veces nos ponemos a pensar que
estamos haciendo con nuestra vida la
estamos aprovechando o no estamos
afinando por cosas que no tienen
importancia porque te van a recordar las
personas que te aman las personas que
están alrededor tuyo porque te van a
recordar a ti qué legado les vas a dejar
que huella vas a dejar en este mundo que
no solamente sea la huella de carbón que
dejes en este mundo sino que sea una
huella realmente que influye en las
personas de forma positiva y en resumen
lo único que puedo decirles la vida es
demasiado corta para no ser feliz vivan
intensamente amen intensamente digan lo
que tienen que decir a la persona que
deben decirlo y háganlo ya porque no
saben si mañana la tendrán perdonen hoy
porque mañana no es posible que a lo
mejor estemos en esta tierra y aunque
suene trillado definitivamente el día
que tenemos para disfrutarlo para
aprovecharlo es hoy
vivan intensamente y recuerden la vida
es demasiado corta como para no ser
feliz muchas gracias
en la zona
aquí
pues el tiempo
[Música]